[Music]
what would a red carpet be without a
spotlight on men's fashion the oscars
are no exception with stars coming out
in full force after a couple years off
and we couldn't be happier we had rami
and prada elliott and gucci jacob and
burberry and will and dolce gabbana but
there were a few gentlemen who stepped
outside the fashion box so let's round
up who rocked the red carpet this year
we love a bromance especially when it's
this stylish spider-man no way home star
andrew garfield stole our hearts in a
burgundy saint laurent jacket and black
pants while jamie dornan kept it classic
in a black valentino tuxedo also in
valentino our homegrown talent simulio
who stepped out in a canadian color red
the chongqi star kept it cool with
patent loafers and a velvet bow tie and
color was key on the carpet with oscar
winner daniel kaluuya in bright teal
david oyelowo in neon yellow floral
print and power of the dog nominee cody
smith mcphee in baby blue bottega
danetta suit and a cartier watch that
was literally dripping with diamonds
speaking of sparkle timothy chalamet
slayed this custom louis vuitton
stepping out on the red carpet shirtless
with a high-waisted pant cropped sparkle
jacket and that rock star vibe timothy's
doomed co-star jason momoa opting this
year for an upcycled tuxedo from seville
row and bowtie showing his support for
ukraine with a blue and yellow pocket
square and bringing back a favorite
accessory from last year his pink
scrunchie that this time tied off his
braid